[Music]
tim is in hartford connecticut hi tim
how are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i'm a longtime listener and a first time
caller so it's hard to start the call
with telling you you're wrong but if
you're hearing me out for one second
people say how are you and you say
better than i deserve
with the amount of people you have
helped with the amount of lives you have
changed
giving people encouragement and changing
their lives you're not better than you
deserve you are deserved of everything
you have and i thank you for all you've
done you're very kind sir you're very
kind it's a theological statement i
deserve hell and i'm not going because
of jesus okay so it's a statement of
grace but yeah i appreciate it
absolutely yeah and it shows your
humility but thank you for changing our
lives
i got a 401k question for you
uh i understand the 401ks plan is for
the long term and we don't freak out
right now because the market's down and
that kind of stuff
however knowing that we're in a bear
market
why wouldn't i put a big hunk of my 401k
into kind of a guaranteed fund
to stop these losses for
x number of months until the market
turns around so that when it does i'm
starting to build again on a higher
balance not a lower balance
the problem is if you knew when the
market was going to turn around
you would be running wall street
true true and i know you can't time the
market but obviously exactly
which is exactly what you're trying to
do
yeah i agreed um but i think everybody's
in agreement that it's not going to
recover
in the very near future
who's integrated
i don't know if you mean if you mean by
friday i agree with you if you mean by
september i'm not sure if i know that
yeah yeah true no we don't know that for
sure but uh
you know there's the losses are so big
now i just keep looking back and saying
had i put it in this guaranteed fund i'd
be 200 000 dollars ahead in my 401k yeah
but every dollar you're buying now when
it comes back
you're going to be 200 000 ahead with
you'll have more regret on that side
you're like man i should have left it in
there and bought more when it was on
sale it's on sale man true true i i
would be foregoing the growth but the
answer to your question is i personally
have not touched my 401 k have you
george shame leave it alone i'm loading
it up i am tempted to actually put more
into the market right now but i as a
matter of principle don't try to time
the market so i'm not going to do that
but i think the market's on sale i think
it's a great buy right now and i'm kind
of excited